انتهت الجوله الاولى من مباحثات دمج
الاقليه الارمنيه في اقليم ناغورنو
كاراباخ من دون الاعلان عن اتفاق في هذا
الشان بين جانب الاذربيجاني وممثلي
الارمني في الاقليم وقد طالب الجانب
الارمي في المحادثات التي تنعقد في
اذربيجان برعايه روسيه مما سماها ضمانات
امنيه كما اتهم الجميع بما فيهم روسيا
والغرب وارمينيا بالتخلي عنهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما ابرز الملفات التي
تبحثها المفاوضات بين الجانبين
الاذربيجاني والارمني بشان اقليم كاراباخ
وما ابرز العقبات التي تعترض التوصل الى
اتفاق بشانها ما طبيعه الضمانات التي
يطالب بها الجانب الارميني من اجل اكمال
الاتفاق مع باكو وما الحجج التي تسوقها
اذربيجان لرفض منح ارمله هذه الضمانات وما
فرص صمود الاتفاق على حل مشكله الاقليه
الارمنيه فيناغورنو كاراباخ ومتى داعيات
الاقليميه المحتمله لهذه القضيه في ضوء
مواقف دول الاقليم من تطوراتها
[موسيقى]
في جوله مباحثات اعقبت جوله عسكريه خاطفه
قادتها اذربيجان ضد تشكيلات ارمنيه مسلحه
في اقليم ناغورنو كاراباخ التقى قرب
العاصمه باكو وفد يمثل الحكومه اذربيجانيه
بممثلين عن الاقليه الارمنيه للبحث اكمال
اتفاق وقف اطلاق نار وافق عليه المسلحون
الارمن عبر مناقشه عده نقاط بينها قضايا
اعاده ادماج السكان الارمن في كاراباخ
وترميم البنيه التحتيه في الاقليم وتنظيم
العمل وفقا لدستور وقوانين جمهوريه
اذربيجان الجوله الاولى من المحادثات التي
تجري برعايه روسيا انتهت من دون الاعلان
عن التوصل الى نتائج محدده رغم وصف
الرئاسه الاذربيجانيه الجوله بانها كانت
بناء ونهى انعقدت في اجواء ايجابيه
مستشار زعيم ارمني اقليمي كاراباخ ديفيد
بابيان قال رغم تاكيده ان المفاوضات يمكن
ان تؤدي الى معاهده سلام تضع نهايه للصراع
قال ان موضوع تسليم سلاحهم لباكو لا يزال
بحاجه الى حل لان الضمانات الامنيه التي
سيحصل عليها الارمن ما زالت غير معروفه
بحسب قوله اضاف باب بيان ان ارمن كاراباخ
لا يريدون العيش كجزء من اذربيجان كما
اتهم الجميع بما فيهم روسيا والغرب
وارمينيا بالتخلي عن كرباخ
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باكو
فؤاد شيراكوف نائب مدير مركز دراسات جنوب
القوقاز ومعنى من يريفان الدكتور
اليكساندر ماركاروف مدير الفرع الارمني
لمعهد رابطه دول المستقله مرحبا بكما سيد
او دكتور اليكساندر ماركاروف سنبدا معك
ونسال ما الذي يريده ارمن اقليمي كاراباخ
من وراء هذه المحادثات الجاريه مع باكو
المفاوضات التي بدات اليوم في الواقع كانت
استمرار
للمفاوضات او جهود التي بداتها بدر من جان
قبل يومين
حيث قاموا
باجبار ممثلين الجانب الايراني
بالمجيد الى مدينه ابلاخ وبدا المفاوضات
مع الاذربيجانين
الموضوع المشكله هو هو موضوع يقع ضمن
الجدول الاعمال ليس مساله مناقشه موضوع عن
استقلاليه استقلاله بل الموضوع المهم في
هذه المفاوضات هي المستقبل العلاقات
تلك المنطقه
ومن حيث المبدا المواضيع التي يطرحها باك
حاليا هي دمج
الارمن الى دوله اذ ربيجان في حين ان
الارمن بالتاكيد
لابد ان يحلوا مشاكل قضيه مثلا حصولهم على
حكم ذاتي كامل
في حينها ليس هناك فرصه كبيره لمواصله
القتال من اجل الحصول على الاستقلال
وبالتالي المشاكل الموضوع لا نتعلق
بالضمانات التي تقدم للسكان الامن في
حفظ كرامتهم وامكانيه ان يتركوا
موطنهم الذي عاش فيه اجيال كثيره من
الارمل
سيد ماركاروخ تحدثت عن نقاط متعدده ولكن
دعنا نتوقف عند مساله الضمانات الامنيه ما
نوع الضمانات الامنيه التي يسعى اليها
الارمن يسعون للوصول اليها في هذه
المفاوضات
من حيث المبدا الضمانات الامنيه التي يجب
يتوقع ان تكون مضمونه ليس ليس ليس فقط
تقوم تقدمها وحكومه
اذربيجان التي لم تقم باحترام حقوق
الانسان لذلك لابد للارمن يحصل الضمانات
امنيه
لحريه ان يعيشوا في من في موطنهم وكما ذكر
ذكر اليوم ممثل المجتمع
الاتحاد الاوروبي فان المسؤولين
الاوروبيين سيعالجون هذا الموضوع بطريقه
شديده
وسيناقشون امكانيات
اجراء او الحصول على نوع من
الاتفاق مع اذربيجان او القيام بشيء ما ضد
اذربيجان اذا ما انتهكت حقوق الارمن في
قرباك وبالتالي لا يعتقد الكثير من الناس
بان حقوق الارمن يمكن ضمانها وتحقيقها
تحت هذا النظام الاستبدادي الذي يحكم
استهباكه وبالتالي وجه المشكله الرئيسي هي
الحصول على الضمان لحفظ حياه وامن الارمل
هو امكانيه دولتهم ليستخدموا لغتهم
وثقافتهم هو ان
يعيشوا بالطريقه التي عاشوها لعقودنا
لقرون من الزمن
نظر بيجاني ما الذي يسعى الى تحقيقه من
وراء هذه المفاوضات
اولا دعوني
اوضح النقطه هذه لم تكن حربا شامله بل
كانت عمليه محليه او اجراءات محليه
مكافحه ارهاب ضد مجموعات مسلحه موجوده على
ارض معترف بها رسميا كجزء من اراضي
جمهوريه اذربيجان الامل النهائي كان هو
ازاله
الالغام التي قتلت سبعه مدنيين
بالطبع هذا العمل
كان بسبب استمرار رفض
الارمن في قرابه
ورفضهم الانخراط في مفاوضات مباشره مع
ضربه جان عرضت عليهم مرتين او ثلاث مرات
على الاقل لكن في كل مره من قرب رفضوا ذلك
وفي اخر لقاء كان ينبغي ان يتم في الاول
من سبتمبر بعد ان تم الاتفاق عليه بعد
وساطه امريكيه
لكنهم رفضوا الحضور علاوه على ذلك
كثيرا في تاريخ ما يحصل الان نحن نعرف ان
اذربيجان قامت بعمليه عسكريه وحسمت
ميدانيا لصالحها ونحن الان امام هذه
المحادثات ما الذي تسعى اليه اذربيجان ما
الذي تريد الحصول عليه من وراء هذه
المحادثات
نعم طيب
ما تحاول اجر بيتان القيامه به هو تعزيز
خطه الدمج لان هذه القوى العسكريه غير
الشرعيه كانت موجوده على الارض
كعقبه الرئيسيه تعترض هذه الخطط وهذه
المجموعات العسكريه غير القانونيه كانوا
ياخذون
رهائن من السكان محليين يرهبون سكان
المحليين ويخيفونهم
وعلى ماذا ثلاثه عقود على الاقل كانت هذه
الممارسات تتم وهذه القوات غير الشرعيه
كان ينبغي ان تسحب من الاقليم في
2022 وفقا للماده الرابعه من الاتفاق
الثلاثي الذي وقعته روسيا واذربيجان
ارمينيا
لكن ارمينيا رفضت ذلك
ونفت ان لديها قوات عسكريه لها وجود داخل
الاراضيانيه لكن يوم امس
اعترفوا بان هناك هناك قوات سيتم سحبها
الان
بعد سحب هذه القوات غير الشرعيه اعلن
الرئيس
خطط للمستقبل
فيما يتعلق
بالحقوق البلديه الحقوق الثقافيه حقوق
الاجتماعيه
اذربيجان سوف تقوم
بتوفير سكان اقليم
مجموعه كامله من الحقوق التي يتمتع بها
بقيه
مواطني اذربيجان اذربيجان وعلى خلاف ارمين
ارمينيا بلد فيه ثقافه واحده وعرقيه واحده
لكن اذربيجان متعدد الاعراق والثقافات وفي
حرب قرباغه الاولى وقر حرب قربغه الثانيه
المسيحيون
واليهود والذين ينتمون الى عرقيات مختلفه
خاضوا الحرب طوعيا ودافعوا عن سياده اراضي
اذربيجان اذا الزعم بان حقوق
الاقليه العرقيه يتم تمييز ضدهم داخل
الاراضي اذربيجان لا اساس لها من الصحه
وكل السجلات تثبت ما نقول اذربيجان
في هذه الامور كلها السيد الكساندر ماركا
روف اذا سيد دكتور اليكساندر ماركاروف
واضحه المطالب الاذربيجانيه عدم تسليح
مجموعات في داخل الاقليم مجددا بما يشكل
انتهاكا لوقف اطلاق النار وربما الاتفاق
اتفاق سلام نهائي
والحديث عن حقوق هذه الاقليات الارمنيه من
ضمن دوله اذربيجان ما المشكله اذا
المشكله هي من حيث مدى ليس هناك ضمانات
يمكن فعلا ان نراها وللمسها فيما نظرا
للسجل اذربيجان في هذا المجال فعلتهم
معروف معروف ان الجيش
والذين قاموا بالكثير من الهجمات والقصف
منذ كانوا في دبوتا بيست السجل اذربيجان
معروف جدا
ولو فهم يعترفوا الناس دوله ذات عده
عروق وقوميات ولكن رغم ذلك فانهم في منطق
النخيل جيرمان قبل 15 سنه قاموا
بمكافحه الارمن وبنفس الوضع يحصل فيه
الاراضي
التي كانت تحت سيطره اذربيجان بعد حرب
وبالتالي فالحديث عن التسامح والتساهل لا
لا غير مؤكد نظرا لاست لتاريخ هذه الدوله
فالارمن في قربت وحكومه
ارمينيا والمجتمع الدولي كلهم يطلبون ان
يكون
لديهم ضمانات
ان كان ان كان الموقف من السلطات في باكو
ومن الحكومه في اذربيجان بالشكل الذي
وصفته لنا ما قيمه اي ضمانات ان كان
المنطلق انه لا يمكن الثقه بهؤلاء ما قيمه
اي ضمانات يسعى اليها الجانب الارمني
لهذا السبب هم يطلبون ضمانات امنيه دوليه
لذلك بعد حرب 2020 كان هناك قوات حفظ
السلام روسيه حاولت ان تحافظ على وضع وقت
اطلاق النار والذي
كانت تنتهكوا
قبل يومين جان وفي الواقع ان ذلك لم يكن
فقط ضد العسكريين بل حتى كان هجومهم على
المدنيين
ان هناك حديث عن سياسه ما يتعلق بامن
وسلامه الارمن في كربل فكيف يمكن ان يبرر
انه لمده عشر سنوات الطريق الذي يربط
ارمينيا بقره
اغلقته القوات
الغربجانيه ولم يسمحوا بالتايب بضاعه ان
تعبر الى وبالتالي بدات بعمليه فرم مجاعه
على الناس
وهذا كشف الوجه الحقيقي لحكومه اذربيجان
لهذا السبب مره اخرى هناك اصرار بانه هناك
ضمانات امنيه دوليه
سكان المدنيه
وذلك كجزء من
كل ما تقوم هل باكو مستعده للتعامل مع هذا
المطلب ربما منح مثل هكذا ضمانات امنيه
لسكان كاراباخ من اجل بناء الثقه
واعاده دمج هؤلاء في
في اذربيجان كما كما قلت لنا
حسنا اولا
دعوني اختلف مع الدكتور
اليوم نيكول باسميان الرئيس وزراء ارمينيا
اعترف
وصرح بانه لم تكن لم تكن هناك
اصابات كبيره في صفوف السكان الارمن
المدنيين
والذي تم الحديث عنه في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
الارمينيه رئيس وزراء ارمينيا
اكد ذلك
انا
مستغرب من نفسي لانني في المره الاولى
اشكر رئيس وزراء ارمينيا على صدقه
الضمانات الامنيه حتى نستفيد من الوقت سيد
فؤاد لو سمحت ماذا عن هذه الضمانات
الامنيه هل باكو مستعده لاعطائها
فيما يتعلق بالضمانات الامنيه
اذربيجان حتى الان فعلت كل ما تستطيع
لتفادي وقوع اصابات في صفوف المدنيين
ثانيا
وكما اسلبته وبلد متعدد
الاعراق وهناك اناس ينتمون الى ديانات
مختلفه
وقعت على عدد كبير من الاتفاقيات الدوليه
التي تضمن حقوقها الاعراق
والمختلفه ارمينيا بلد فيها عرقيه واحده
وفي العام 88 40
دعني اسالك سؤال بطريقه اخرى يعني في ظل
في ظل هذا التوجس الارميني من ان يكون
اقليم كاراباخ جزءا لو سمحت سيد فؤاد في
ظل هذه التي يعبر عنها الارمن في اقليم
كاراباخ في ان يكون جزءا من
اذربيجان في ظل حديث زعيم مستشار زعيم
ارمن كاراباخ بقوله ان ارمن الاقليم لا
يريدون العيش كجزء من اذربيجان كل هذه
العوامل اضافه الى عامل دخول تركيا ايضا
على هذا الصراع
والعلاقه التاريخيه المتازمه بين ارمينيا
وتركيا كل هذه العوامل كيف ستتعاطى معها
اذربيجان ان كانت لا تريد ان تقدم شيئا
لارمن كاراباخ
اوكي اولا
اثناء
عندما كانت هذه الاراضي تحت احتلال
ارمينيا اذربيجان كانت تقدم اعلى درجات
الحكم الذاتي
لسكان هؤلاء وكانوا يرفضون حقيقه
ووفقا
للتشريعات
الارمينيه هم تم تم ضم هذه الاراضي الى
ارمينيا انظروا الى دستور المينا فهو
يتحدث عن ضم هذه الاراضي كل بلدان العالم
حتى في منطقتنا هذه البلدان فيها تعدديه
عرقيه اذا كان علينا ان نغير حدود كل
البلدان وفقا لوجود كل هذه الاعراق لن
يكون هناك حياه طبيعيه اذا ارمينيا عندما
احتلت هذه البلدان لم يكون الحديث عن حق
الحكم الذاتي وتقرير المصير هم احتلت
مناطق كان فيها الاغر بيجانين
99% من السكر كان ذلك احتلالا هذا لم يكن
له علاقه بحقوق ولا بتحقق تقرير المصير
الان يمارسون اللعيب ليبراليه يريدون ان
يلعبون دور الضحيه وورقه الضحيه اعتقد
فؤاد هل هذا ما نفهمه منك لا ضمانات امنيه
سيد فؤاد
لا ضمانات امنيه هل هذا ما نفهمه منك
كل الضمانات الامنيه تتوفر في تشريعاتها
التي
تحملتها بتوقيعها على كل اتفاقيات احترام
حقوق الانسان احترامي حقوق الاقليات هذا
كل ما هو في الامر
ارمينيا التي اكدت انها لم تكن جزءا من
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار بين الجانب
الاذربيجاني وارمني اقليمي كاراباخ قال
رئيس وزرائها نيكول باشنيان الذي تظاهر
الاف المعارضين الارمنيين لسياسته تجاه
اقليم كاراباخ ان بلاده بحاجه الى تحرر من
الصراع من اجل استقلالها ومستقبلها بالرغم
من صعوبه هذا المسار بحسب تعبيره وقد عبر
المتظاهرون كذلك عن استيائهم من الموقفين
الروسي والامريكي تجاه لاغورنو كاراباخ
حيث كانت موسكو قد اعلنت ان قضيه كاراباخ
مساله داخليه اذربيجانيه بينما اكتفت
واشنطن
يؤدي اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار لتجنب المزيد
من العنف
دكتور الكسندر ماركا روف على ماذا يعتمد
اقليم كاراباخ في مطالبهم هذه كما قال لنا
السيد فؤاد لا ضمانات امنيه يبدو ان حتى
رئيس وزراء ارمينيا بنفسه عما يحدث في
الاقليم باعتراف مسؤوليه الاقليم الذين
يقولون الجميع تخلى عنا بما في ذلك
ارمينيا وروسيا والغرب على ماذا يعتمد
اقليم كاراباخ في هذه المفاوضات اذا وفي
مطالبهم هذه
انهم يعتمدون على قدرتهم على الدفاع عن
انفسهم
لديهم جيشهم الخاص بهم الذي
تعرض الى ضرب
يعني عند هذه النقطه
ايضا ان تحسمها في غضون 24 ساعه
60 الف شخص يقاتلون
حوالي
وكل بلد لو معدات عسكريه جيده جدا وصلته
من اسرائيل ومن تركيا فالنتيجه هذا
المعركه بالتاكيد واضح
على ماذا الاعتماد اذا دكتور الكسندر في
غياب كل عوامل القوه هذه التي ذكرتها لك
في بدايه اليوم كانوا يعملون انه انه كان
قوات حفظ السلام الروسيه التي
نشرت بعد نهايه العمليات العسكريه في
نوفمبر 2020 ولكن مع الاسف هذه القوه
العسكريه المحدوده لم تستطع ان توقف
القوات العسكريه الاذربيجانيه التي ارتكبت
هذه الاعمال وعندنا ان نتحدث عن المجتمع
الدولي
فمعظمهم قدروا عن قلقهم قلقهم الشديد حول
ما يحصل
وتدهور الوضع
ما يتعلق بالاقليه اذا ليس هناك امال
كبيره ملقات على المجتمع الدولي كما
شاهدنا وبالتالي فيلم مفاوضات بين
السلطات الاذربيجانيه
سلطات كهرباء قد تطرح موضوع
مساله ضمانات امنيه دوليه للاسف
يعني انتهى وقتنا الدكتور الكسندر ماركا
روف مدير الفرع الارمني لمعهد رابطه دول
المستقله من ياريفان وشكرا للسيد فؤاد
شيراكوف من باكو نائب ومدير مركز دراسات
جنوب القوقاز
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]